[MUSIC]
I'm currently here in Osaka, Japan.
>> I'm from Nigeria,
>> From Hong Kong.
>> I'm an entrepreneur from Israel.
>> I'm from Karachi, Pakistan.
>> From Atlanta, Georgia,
>> I'm mostly from Texas
>> I'm from Honolulu, Hawaii.
>> Hey I'm a Japanese diplomat and
a samurai.
>> I am from Chile.
>> I'm from Portugal.
>> I'm from Dallas, Texas,
by the way of Sudan.
>> From the Windy City, Chicago, Illinois.
>> Los Angeles.
>> I'm from Augusta, Georgia,
and my family's originally
from Antigua in the Caribbean.
>> And I'm currently about an hour outside
of Yosemite National Park en route
to the GSB.
>> A fun fact about me.
Is that I used to be a real life cowboy.
>> One fun fact that I will throw out
there is I have an EP dropping out
in about a month.
So do check that out shameless plug
>> I was twice
the Israeli breakdance
champion when I was 16.
>> Fun fact,
I grew up right next to Disneyland and
went to Disney elementary school.
>> After college, I joined
a professional Bollywood dance company.
>> I'm excited to master
the art of virtual hugs.
>> Fun fact about me is that my first
career was as a music producer.
>> One fun fact about me is I'm a level
eight arcane trickster in dungeons and
dragons.
>> My fun fact is that I speak
four different languages.
>> I have an incredibly lazy
French Bulldog, named Zelda.
>> A fun fact about myself
is that I unicycled once for
a talk about commercial aired on
the NBA All Star basketball game.
>> I'm married with a two year old son and
have another son who's come in
two weeks after school starts.
>> One fun fact about me
is that I really enjoy more
pineal worms which are a caterpillar
that's eaten in southern Africa.
>> I'm currently serving as
an Army helicopter pilot.
And I think the thing that
I'm looking most forward to
is joining this next chapter of my life
with a cohort of just amazing people.
>> What I'm most excited about
is meeting all these amazing
students that are going to
be in the GSB community.
>> There's such good energy,
incredible people as part of our class, so
it's going to be very invigorating and
energizing to finally be on campus.
Alongside all of you.
>> I am so excited to get to the GSB and
meet all of the incredible people
who I know are my classmates.
>> I think it's really rewarding to
hear what my classmates are thinking.
And I really enjoy that
space to share perspective.
>> I hope we can raise
the barrel of the creativity and
optimism of this community and
really rise to the occasion.
>> Stay true to your mission.
>> Celebrate that you
have gotten through and
know that you are capable of
getting through anything.
>> Thank you for believing in yourself and
taking that risk.
Now go and pay that forward to the world.
>> Be proud.
Stay humble.
>> So cheers to class of 2022.
And to all of you who are strangers now
that by the time you see this video,
I'm sure we'll all be friends.
[SOUND]
[MUSIC]